with all the the chaos these days about
inflation
and you know all the nonsense that's
going on in the world
you know you know what's getting a bad
name these days cash
call me crazy
but cash ain't dead baby
you know ray dalio took a lot of heat
before the pandemic he said cash is
trash
cash is trash yeah maybe if you're worth
a billion dollars cash is trash you can
diversify your portfolio you can only
have five percent in cash most people
cash ain't dead baby yeah save that
money ain't dead save that money ain't
going anywhere david right amen okay so
yes inflation's happening i get it
but
i recommend having some cash on hand
okay so it is essentially important i
know i've i've gone to almost blows with
uncle robert kiyosaki about this kind of
stuff cash ain't [ __ ] yes it is save
that money no it's not zimbabwe dollars
invest real estate debt save that money
is bad i've had problems so
you know i say save that money and
people actually think that like have you
ever heard of investing no no tell me
more what what's that
yeah yeah of course i've heard but in
order to invest those levels to this
game you got to have that cash you got
to save that money and work your way up
to investing not the other way around a
lot of people these days they see what's
going on with crypto and nfts and so
much money being made that they're all
in investing they're buying stuff on
margin taking on debt to invest
[ __ ] could come crumbling down any
minute if you don't have cash on hand an
emergency fund a rainy day fund or what
i like to call a cushion you're gonna be
left out in the cold okay
so
here are actually the top four reasons
that you should have an emergency fund
if you're an investor okay okay if you
haven't started investing yet you just
look working on cash i get it you're not
going to be like why would i have cash
but a lot of investors are like all my
money's in the market 90 of my net worth
straight up is in the stock market
wow okay whether that's index funds
whether that's
um 401k whether that's a roth ira i own
some bitcoin
90 of my wealth
is um
in the market in appreciating assets but
you best believe i got a hundred grand
in cash just sitting there god forbid
this world comes crumbling apart okay
that peace of mind that peace of mind
baby now let's get into it here are the
four reasons that you should have cash
on hand if you're an investor number one
is just straight up risk
okay
you know the stock market has made quite
the recovery okay but it's still risky
you know you know how much the stock
market is up to s p when i talked about
the s p 500 do you know how much how
much it's up this year alone how much 16
not bad
a healthy return sir because on average
it turn returns around 10 10 a year eric
needs to get in on that stock market
they're losing out 16 investment there
it is roi
but it's no guarantee that it's going to
go up forever so there's a lot of risk
when you're investing this is basic
stuff but this is why you need to have
cash because if the market tanks or your
investment portfolio goes down and you
need cash it's like you don't want to
pull out of that you want to pull out a
loss because you only realize these
losses or gains when you sell
right you're saying i'm saying right
there yeah i'm following okay
number two great segway
cash equals
peace of mind
this is so underrated
this is so underrated because if you've
got yes again
you know
yes there's inflation no you're not
earning ridiculous returns on your
bitcoin but you do have peace of mind if
you're sitting on cash now when we talk
about an emergency fund a lot of people
will recommend that you have six months
saved up for an emergency fund right six
months me i'm like double it
double it 12 months [ __ ] it
cash
okay
god forbid something happens i love
having cash yeah i do
okay some people might say i have too
much cash sitting on the sidelines i'm
good bro
you know how good it feels
to wake up
and no matter what happens today no
matter what happens this week no matter
what happens this month no matter what
happens this year i'm okay
yeah do you know that feeling have you
ever had that feeling um
no no
most people don't have that peace of
mind because they don't have enough cash
saved up or they don't have that much
investments that they can you know lean
on when the bad times come but if you
play your cards right david 100 episodes
in you're going to have that peace of
mind
okay wait episode 15 there we go
here we go so anyway so people say three
to six from an emergency fund i say look
12 months whatever that is
at minimum i say 10 grand yeah 10 grand
changed my life
it's just
i remember being 26 and i didn't have
two nickels i started making money by
the time i was 27 all of a sudden i had
a little bit more than 10 grand like it
took some time year and a half sales job
what have you
dude life changes
stress goes away issues happen flat tire
cool here's 100 bucks
right
someone's wedding birthday gift cool 400
but whatever it is
peace of mind how much i mean i mean how
much how much
but it's it's it's true yeah it's true
it's an anniversary you're gonna spend
500 bucks on a nice gift
deal me up sign me up
big deal um number three number three
not every dollar that you have needs the
maximum return
right we get so caught up in i gotta get
a return on my investment return on
investment roi return on medicine yeah
but that's not for every single dollar
some dollars can just be in cash you
know they talk about there's such low
interest rates these days why would you
be in cash you're basically losing money
to inflation and you're not making any
money uh you have zero roi on your cash
that's fine
that's not what cash is for that's not
what your emergency fund is for your
emergency fund and your cash on the
sidelines your cushion has nothing to do
with return it has everything to do with
security
feeling safe
david do you ever just want to feel safe
all the time yeah you know i see you go
up to your lady friend you say just give
me a hug
i want to feel safe in your arms
see it all the time
there's kiki over here he wants to feel
safe mostly i do it mostly with eric and
i'm like hey can i just get a hug real
quick man
exactly
but
um
it has everything to do with security as
you know again
talking about myself 90 of my net worth
is in investments it's making a rate of
return put my money out to work compound
interest
all that fun stuff
the staple
you know yeah is cash it's like if
you're traveling yeah so i like i'm
gonna use some more travel analogies i
got something for you
but if you're traveling and you're going
to go around the world your investments
that's your luggage you're putting that
on the plane
you know good luck i'll see you in
london i hope
right yeah but your cash that shit's
right on your carry-on that's on your
person that's on you okay the
investments risk reward all that cash on
deck keep that on you keep it on your
person okay
so not every dollar needs the maximum
return there's a reason that warren
buffett in the news right now has 150
billion dollars worth of cash on hand he
could deploy that at any second he says
no
something's up out there
something's smelly grandpa warren
sitting on cash okay because when you
have cash
you have options
and opportunities
options come your way hey man i need uh
i'll talk about this with bitcoin
options coming your way boom seize the
moment opportunity boom i had cash
the whole point of the investment is
like it's out there keep it out there
don't touch it cash all right what are
we gonna do with this emergency fund
make some moves opportunities cool there
it is
warren buffett all over the news right
now 150 billion dollars cash just
sitting there pat talked about this in
the podcast what's he doing with all
that this is something let me know
something we don't know you want you to
handle that okay and then this is number
four i love all these things not taking
on too much risk having peace of mind
understanding that every dollar doesn't
need a maximum return but most of all
i like the ability to make moves
making moves david this is what i would
call flexibility
right i'm living in miami i got to go to
dallas boom i'm renting cool done done
with my lease i got cash boom moving
we're back in boca boom all right cool
now we're moving to fort lauderdale boom
making moves flexibility low overhead
and high flexibility is the key to life
these days let me say that again
low overhead and high flexibility is the
key to life these days the world is
moving so fast these days things are
happening so quickly around us we don't
know what the hell's going on but if
you've got low overhead yeah like if you
only have a couple thousand bucks of
expenses each month right maybe it's a
little bit more than that and you have
the crazy flexibility dude i'm going to
move to new york i'm moving a new
opportunity taking a new job moving to
austin making moves i'm in boston i'm in
austin i'm in austin i'm in boston which
one is it i don't know i'm flexible as
[ __ ]
hell yeah
buys you opportunities exactly so this
the world has never been this chaotic
and changing so fast you got to have
your head on a swivel you got to be able
to pivot and it's never
been
more valuable to just be able to have
cash to make moves that's it so people
say the cash is trash cash is still king
in my book okay inflation six percent
inflation and all
cash is still king
okay because once you can master the
cash flow game that's when you can start
investing not the other way around right
start investing and then figure out what
to do with the cash is money all we talk
is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken